I wanted to ask you am I correct that
you wrote this song too fat to fly
the song yeah was it did you write a
song called No I was involved in an
incident
that I called and then others adopted as
too fat to fly when I got thrown off of
a Southwest Air airplane and I was
tweeting about it and it [ __ ] went
viral I think it was Johnny Knoxville's
cousin Roger Allen Wade the country
singer who wrote a song too fat to fly
it might have been after I'm not
certainly not taking credit but it could
have been inspired by that is so so wow
that it was now
getting kicked off an airplane for being
too fat it was they were never like they
never gave me a clear thing there's
somebody who wasn't from Southwest who
was like look I know a little bit about
Airlines and when an airplane is fully
loaded and that plane was like fully
loaded and it was absolutely the last
one on I was supposed to be on the next
flight but I was like oh [ __ ] there's a
seat on this plane [ __ ] I'll get on it
so this person who's involved with
Airlines is just like they have weights
on planes and like
you were just the last person on it
wasn't like you're too [ __ ] fat for
this plane they were like we're over the
weight limit somebody's got to go who's
the last person that came on they're
like that guy out he goes how much did
you weigh at that time
over three bills I think I weighed my my
like uh area code at that point three
two three wow yeah yeah but still I wore
it fairly well I'm not gonna say like I
you know I could [ __ ] fool you and
[ __ ] but I I did it was always spread
out fairly well so much so that people
were like really you were that [ __ ]
happy
um but yeah that was
the center after the heart attack that
was way before maybe way before when was
the heart attack heart attack was four
and a half years ago and well four years
ago in February that just passed what
does that feel like it was
didn't feel like a heart attack you know
I was raised on [ __ ] 70s television
so I was waiting to Fred Sanford that
[ __ ] like what's up you know you're
supposed to be big clutch your chest
[ __ ] yell somebody's name and real I
just couldn't quite catch my breath and
I was between performances I was doing a
show at uh the Alex theater in uh
Pasadena I think or Glendale Glendale
and um we were shooting him for a
Showtime special you know when you do a
show that you shoot two shows and then
they combine it into sure into one so we
shot the first show and I got backstage
and also I just couldn't quite like
catch my breath and I was like um can
everyone get out of here I just want to
like lay down for a second and [ __ ]
because we had another show in like 45
minutes and then I was like sweating
profusely and couldn't quite like catch
my breath that was it didn't feel
anything didn't feel chest pain or
anything like that and so Jason's wife
Jordan she runs our company
she was like concerned because she's
like I never see you like this so she
called an ambulance and at one point she
hadn't told me at one point I finally
broke down I was like you know what I
feel very [ __ ] up like maybe we should
call a doctor she's like it's Sunday
night all the doctors are closed so I
called the ambulance and I was like why
the [ __ ] would you do that this is
embarrassing I just smoked too much weed
that's all the problem is and the First
Responders came and they these two kids
this guy and this girl you know like in
production as you're well aware they put
together a call sheet for those that
don't know that is all the information
you need for the shoot that day who's on
it who does what who it [ __ ] what time
you're starting and so forth there's
also information like in case of an
emergency this is the hospital that we
go to so there was a hospital on the
call sheet that you know was way close
to the theater
the kids the First Responders decided to
take me to a further hospital because
they were heart specialists so they made
the call they didn't even tell me I was
having a heart attack they put these
[ __ ] leads on me I was more concerned
with how they wanted to like uh take my
shirt off because they're like we gotta
attach it leads to at one point the guy
went to just hike my hockey jersey up I
was like whoa yanked it down every
[ __ ] tit I got is gonna fall out of
you he was like well we gotta get these
leads on you I was like well you can
[ __ ] reach under I'll hold out the
hockey jersey
as a god post and go ahead so I was
giving them a problem because I was like
embarrassed and stuff about my body all
my body shame issues and wanna and they
in the midst of all that they were like
had presence of mind to be like this
motherfucker's having a heart attack
we should bring him to the heart attack
gospel and say brought me to Adventist
and uh that made the difference it was
this guy Mark ladenheim Dr ladenheim Who
I get into the to the emergency room
and he's like uh hi
how you feeling and I was like I feel
like fine I just can't catch my breath
can't like I could breathe but I can't
reach the top and come back down and he
was just like uh well you know what's
your pain level on a scale of zero to
ten
and I was like pain like negative three
and he's like oh that's [ __ ] up he's
like you're doing it all wrong I was
like doing it wrong he said yeah he's
supposed to be in a lot of pain when you
have a heart attack
I was like am I you're saying I'm having
a heart attack you're having a massive
heart attack right now he's like we got
to go very very fast so I'm gonna meet
you upstairs in the OR and then they
turn me over to a guy who was just like
um I gotta shave your groin because
that's how the doctor's gonna get into
your heart so can you take your Jorts
off or whatever and so uh I was like
um well I don't want to do that in front
of all these people you know [ __ ]
here you are everybody there and I don't
give a [ __ ] like everybody got their own
emergency going on but like we've all
been in New York I don't care if your
mom's dying sooner or later look around
and be like what the [ __ ] you know so
sooner or later somebody's gonna look
around and be like Silent Bob and his
dick out so I was like I'm not I'm not
taking off my my uh Jordans death before
dishonor truly was truly wasn't the
dude's like are you kidding we gotta go
and I was like well what if I just like
pull my [ __ ] Jorts over to the side
and you could just give me a virgin
smoothie or whatever
and he's like uh do you know realize
we're wasting time I was like look man
that dude that dude who was just here he
told me I had a heart attack if you make
me take my pants off and go dick out in
this room I'm have a second heart attack
that's gonna be on you so they got me up
to the or and the doctor's like why is
his pants still on and the guy was like
he's got body shame issues I was like
Doc I got a really small dick he goes we
don't have time for this he yanked my
[ __ ] off like I was in the 70s porn man
and [ __ ] went to work so they in
order to uh you know there's many
different ways to figure out what's
going on in the heart the doctor
suspected it was some sort of blockage
or what the medical people call an
occlusion so he uh threaded a camera up
my femoral artery how to get to it is
two ways they could go in through your
wrist or then going through ephemeral
which is like in your crotch in your
groin area so they puncture a hole and
[ __ ] go up they stick a camera up the
femoral and he's like oh that's exactly
what I thought it was and I was like
what's that he's gone uh you got 100
blockage
um and in your lad that's the name of
the artery that comes down so we gotta
we gotta break it up and and get a stent
in there as soon as possible and it goes
but he's going you're a comic book guy
you like comic books right it doesn't
very much then he's like they got a name
for this heart attack it's called the
Widowmaker he goes doesn't that sound
like a bad guy in a comic book I was
like it does what's it mean as if you
had to ask and he's just like well in
the particular heart attack you're
having with the 100 blockage
eighty percent of the cases the patient
always dies he's going you're gonna be
in the 20 because I'm good at my job and
it disappeared into my crotch and made
magic and [ __ ] so dude saved my [ __ ]
life but while I was on the table
80 20 you know I'm no math genius but I
know that those are terrible [ __ ]
odds you know I figure every time you
leave the house it's 50 50 but 80 20.
man that's terrible so I started going
through the whole like you know well my
life's gonna flash proof of my eyes I'm
gonna start this [ __ ] movie and just
tracked my existence up until that point
and thought about like everything that
worked out and very very little didn't
work out in life and like you know I was
like well if this is it like you you got
a good [ __ ] run like yeah you're only
[ __ ] 47 but like packed a lot of
[ __ ] crazy living in a 47 [ __ ]
year so if this is the end like don't be
a [ __ ] about it just push back from the
table say thank you and [ __ ] go don't
be the last dude struggling to stay at
the party where so you got any more
[ __ ] beer like just oh leave the
[ __ ] party yeah I love that I reached
the place I reached a place of like
total Zen where I was like I'm ready and
then [ __ ] saved my life so I had
to come back to the land of the living
and that's [ __ ] up when you're like
all right I'm ready to die and they're
like well you're not gonna and you're
like oh [ __ ] it's not like I was
suicidal and I wasn't emo and I wasn't
like [ __ ] goth like I just want a
diamond but I was like I get it like my
whole life I've been scared of death and
then on that table maybe it was because
he gave me the odds maybe it's because I
was hopped up on fentanyl who [ __ ]
knows but I sat there going like
you know
this is I remember you know a big big
fan of Neil Gaiman Sandman book which is
now on Netflix as a show but back in the
day it was just comic book and in the
issue about death his sister death who's
personified by this like goth girl and
[ __ ] she's going around collecting Souls
all day you know people that are dying
they're like oh my God I know who you
are and [ __ ] and she takes them wherever
they're gonna go she comes this one guy
older dude and he's just like no no it's
too soon she's going yeah and he's like
well my whole life I had this and he
listed all this [ __ ] like you know
all the [ __ ] he'd been through he's like
all that happened to me and what what
did I get and the death character says
to him you got what everybody gets you
got a life so I was sitting there going
I got a life and [ __ ] that life was
great and it ends like it felt it
occurred to me as graduation it's the
first time in my life I wasn't afraid of
death because I was like oh you can't
stay in high school forever sooner or
later you gotta [ __ ] go and I felt
like I was like yeah truly I get older
they say the same age but but it was
like a moment of like oh it's it's
natural it's right like it was always
you know the enemy to me you know when
you're a creative person or you've
answered yourself a creative person or
you get paid to do creative things for a
living
death is just [ __ ] a slap in the face
it's so insulting it's like what I can't
end I have important [ __ ] to do there's
so much here and I just want to thank
you for how [ __ ] fascinating all of
that was well it's the van that brings
it up and uh Scott Randolph here
like has watched and continues to watch
every night
hundreds thousands of video testimonies
about nde near-death experiences is that
right is that your thing before I go to
bed I watched uh this this guy on
YouTube called Lee wedding
and even Bangor Maine I'm trying to like
reach out to him because I want to meet
up with him but he's like a hospital
chaplain that has a podcast and he
interviews people that have died and
come back and you know they're hard to
stop for four minutes nine minutes
sometimes I think the record's like 30
minutes Mom it happened to my mom long
before I had a heart attack my mom has
always had like heart problems and [ __ ]
and uh
she died on the table and so she you
know [ __ ] had a very familiar story
about like there was a light and did she
go to the light she she described it
well let's all agree that the light is
probably the hospital light you know no
because sometimes people are saying like
you know they're floating above their
body true and then all of a sudden
there's a light in the corner true and
then they go to it and then they go do a
Life review which I'm fascinated by the
life reviews she said she saw like Dad
because my dad died years ago she saw my
grandma she saw familiar people
and she was like
she and then she got yanked back and so
I was like all right Ma
you've been here in this best of all
possible worlds for many years and you
were there for almost a minute
which did you like better and [ __ ]
she [ __ ] me up by going like there
there and I said why and she goes
I felt so light she's gone every [ __ ]
pressure and every every hook in me that
I felt in life all the [ __ ] that I'm
responsible for
I was I was done like suddenly I I was
like oh my God and she was all that
responsibility was was offered I thought
that was really beautiful and when
I was going through my thing so I don't
know if her
thing informed my thing but like I too
once I was just like oh [ __ ] I'm
probably gonna [ __ ] there's a last
ceiling I'm gonna see in is in this room
and you know I was I should have [ __ ]
like terrified me and [ __ ] like that but
the
the the hook of it was that like oh
this is this is
like
I you know I was raised Catholic so
there's supposed to be something after
this and over the years of course I've
let go of that and I've you know I think
Scott Moser we do a podcast where we did
a podcast for years called it's podcast
he had said at one point he was not
raised religious or anything and Mosher
was like
um you know I was talking about dying
long before I ever almost died and I was
like what do you [ __ ] think happens
after this like you don't believe in
heaven come on dude like there's got to
be something after this
and he's like well you believe in heaven
because you were fed that when you were
a kid he's gone but you're way too
logical to really believe in that if you
step aside and think about it who's
going to understand that you were raised
with it and whatnot but like
I don't think it's that and he's going
you believe there's a heaven because
you know you just cannot [ __ ]
stand the notion
that one day you ain't gonna think these
thoughts that the world's not going to
share and the glory of [ __ ] you and
whatnot and he's like but I think I was
like what do you think it is he's gone I
think we're computers he's gone the
computer has a massive amount of
information on it because that's what I
was saying I was like how could I just
[ __ ] stop and die like I have all
this information he was just like a
computer it's packed with information it
could do amazing [ __ ] things he's
gone and then one day just hard drive
spins down and that's it and I was like
[ __ ] that that was the first time it
it really impacted with me where I was
like oh you're right there is no heaven
and I'm not special none of us are and
what we have in this life is what we
have and what we build and that's the
[ __ ] adventure and all these [ __ ]
people that are fed a lot of [ __ ]
about suffering in this world and
[ __ ] you know rewarding the next is
like what a f what a [ __ ]
what a bunch of Hokum that is it's like
you got no nobody [ __ ] knows it's on
the other side and if you really think
about it it's probably nothing so this
is it well Joy is here man there ain't
no joy after this it's just you just
wind down like a computer I I'm with
your mom do you believe in the uh yeah
and and
um I I believe that all religions
effectively uh point to the same
like universal truth which is
distilled down to the words we are one
sure about it we are one and what we are
one means
as I understand it and I think that this
is across all scriptures and and stuff I
meant it is that
uh
creation
um
everything that exists in the universe
is an exercise in God experiencing
itself because God being one thing
cannot
uh have experience because experience is
based on relativity one thing relating
to another and one thing cannot relate
to itself so big bang whatever creation
you want to call it is this one thing
dividing itself into separate particles
which now
can relate to one another because
there's that that separation but the
separation is an illusion it's it's an
illusion which allows for you know uh up
there's no up if there's no down there's
no hot if there's no cold these are all
relative terms and so I another fun way
to distill it down somebody said this to
me and it really stuck we are all eyes
in the same head
so to go to [ __ ] good it's a really
good one to go to to Scott would Scott
bring up with the the Life review
Life review is just beyond
uh indisputable there's just so much
evidence there's so much and Life review
is like the life now I've read an
article
um that's the scientific piece that was
like this is absolutely true yeah you do
experience your life before you die and
I don't know if it's theoretical or if
it's uh Medical but that what they came
up with was
when the body is going through the
trauma of shutting down which is
something we're not familiar with
because most of our Lives the body is
vital and [ __ ] doing the things that
we wanted to do
when the body shuts down it is traumatic
like because the body's not used to like
oh this ain't going to be used no more
we're dying and it shuts down the brain
releases a chemical the DMT keeps you
calm my my question with that is the the
near-death experiences all seem to be
the same maybe it's DMT releasing from
your brain however the people that do
Ayahuasca or that do DMT don't have the
same experiences as that and so I'm
always wondering like if it is the DMT
you never hear somebody come back from
an Ayahuasca trip saying I went to the
light I met my Spirit guides right it's
always another dimension well there's
this that's what I've been trying to
think about is it predisposition like uh
you know everyone sees the same little
green men like the mechanical elves yeah
is it just something that somebody
they've been telling this [ __ ] go to
the light and hey you see everybody in
your old pets and [ __ ] like that it's
interesting for years is it just part of
us now that like even if you're not a
faithful person or a religious person
that is something to cling to in the
darkness like in a world where nobody
[ __ ] knows at least when you've got a
faith you're like well I put my faith in
Jesus and Jesus says it's going to be
this but let's say you don't have a
Jesus
and all you got is [ __ ] like oh that
I'll take that like maybe but how do you
explain like um one of the girls that
died she said um you know I left my body
I went into the other hallways and I saw
she's like I saw my stepdad getting a
Coca-Cola from the vending machine and
he came an hour later and she's like but
I thought it was interesting because
he's always like holier than thou
exercise guy and I she's like I made a
mental note like that's weird he's
getting a Diet Coke and then she kept
going and then when she came back she
said maybe like you know a couple days
later she's like did you get a Diet Coke
out of the vending machine and he was
like how did you know that and it was
like a little secret that he had or he
was eating a Snickers bar I mean there's
like interesting outer body experiences
yeah there's definitely proof in that
regard but I think it's more simple than
whether there's DMT or it's some kind of
uh a physiological thing because all of
these accounts of Life review and again
Life review is your life passing before
your eyes is it they all
take time out of the equation right like
it's it's it's a flash but it's like
that you can see the whole story
that do have Live reviews say they go
through and experience everybody's pain
that I put them through hey Andrew I've
got the gnarlies well that means it's
true the gnarly's Goosebumps like what
the concept of We Are All One We're All
Eyes in the same head right like this
this uh illusion of Separation The Life
review is an is an experience that that
does not
um involve time the detail is is insane
you actually go through
your your whole life and and at the
detail that you can't even like describe
as a human being but you go through your
whole life and you experience your
impact on everything else
every time you made someone happy you're
gonna feel that joy every time he made
someone uh I did more Pro than yeah but
wait the do you get Life review if you
live everybody but like if you're yeah
the near-death experience they they've
had them
um it's like they'll come back and ask
if they had a live review and maybe 20
will say no I didn't but like the
majority are like yeah I one guy went
and he said he his guy took him around
and then he sat him down in a movie
theater and a thing came on and he
watched his movie like there's different
ways to do it yeah and you can
experience how like you can experience
it like as a mosquito that's off in the
distance like so far away from when you
did the most minor thing and like and so
it's just uh I mean can you induce this
huh Can you induce it yeah I guess in
the east coast they have um they shut
off your senses and they're trying to
recreate so when they put you in like an
outer Bank something there's a I've been
trying to look into it and I want to pay
for it to do it you're [ __ ] Searcher
man look at you you're a Seeker good for
you have you ever have you ever been to
a place that you thought was familiar
like I I what I mean by that is like I
think in the past life I was Vietnamese
is that right I think and that was also
Brazilian because I have like a weird
kinship with Vietnamese people and when
I went to Vietnam I was like oh this is
familiar do you have anything like that
I've always loved Canada for no
expectations so I must have been
Canadian and that makes a lot of [ __ ]
sense you know because Canadians are
good people in general so they of course
they'd be reincarnated you know they're
like you're coming back you did it right
you get to do it again maybe in a past
life you're a Canadian I think so it's
got to be there's no good reason to
explain why I like Canada as much as I
do and it's interesting because both of
you guys I mean me too and everybody
like I feel so blessed in this life me
too and I and I and I was asking
somebody about that and they said
because you were probably uh evolved in
a previous life and like you it's like
kind of like a karmic you know I'm
really enjoying this life and the only
way I can explain it is that like I must
have been a really good person in a
previous life is that I don't know I
mean look I'll take that because I like
that but
so do [ __ ] heels get a better life next
time around or does their life get worse
I think like maybe murderers get
reincarnated a little bit lower on the
life
uh I I don't know I think you're looking
at it like far too simplistically and
um and I think that when conversations
with God he asked them how many lives
he's had he's like 700 or whatever he's
like right right right right right right
right I mean but you could choose to
come back to this world if you want when
you go to the other side or you can go
it's the soul contract I mean do you
want to explain that there's there's
there's the assault contract where like
you uh do you have like a blueprint for
what you want to uh to learn experience
what you want to uh remember what when
you know you choose your parents you you
know you go into this and and the
contract that which we uh enter into you
know as we before we incarnate as a body
like the deal is once you incarnate as a
body like you forget the the whole deal
that's like uh there's a movie years and
years and years ago in the late 80s
maybe early 90s called Angel Heart with
Mickey Rourke and he was uh it was a
detective gum economy at least Bonnet
where they the Side Story to that
allegedly I wasn't there I wasn't even
in the movie business but allegedly they
actually had sex while they were
shooting their sex scenes wow that's
like if you go on the internet there's
lots of stories about that in any event
it's a story about a guy Mickey rourke's
a detective who's hired by Robert De
Niro plays a character named Louis
Cipher
figure that out
um he wants him to track down this guy
Johnny Angel who owes him something and
so Mickey rourke's looking for this
[ __ ] guy the whole movie and spoilers
in the third act you find out that he
was Johnny Angel and he made a deal with
the Devil
to like become [ __ ] famous and [ __ ]
like that and they tried to renege on
the deal with the devil and forgot who
he was and so the devil had come to
claim his [ __ ] soul and sent him to
look for it and [ __ ] like that now when
clerks happened to me in 1994
I you know I was not I'm like you I'm an
outsider artist like there was no
manifest that that was going to happen I
lived in New Jersey the [ __ ] it's not
like I lived in California it wasn't
manifest that you could make a hit movie
with twenty seven thousand dollars go
figure
there wasn't so when we clerks like not
when I made it but when it got bought
and when it was clear that like oh my
God like my dream is actually gonna come
true I was convinced that I had Angel
hearted myself that I had made some deal
with the devil and part of the deal was
that I would not remember until it was
too [ __ ] late and [ __ ] now I still
got time in this life I hope I'll find
out that's the [ __ ] case but I like
the notion of the Soul contract where
it's just like you're gonna you get to
pick and choose the menu but you ain't
gonna remember any of this [ __ ] right
I'm like like
also a big researcher big thing and this
one hang up that I have with the the
because in the Saul contract in the
blueprint for life which we agreed to
um there are predetermined events which
are just gonna happen and I can't
existing conditions yeah even afterlife
there's three existing conditions
there's uh well not pre-existing but
predetermined like things that are going
to happen and I just cannot reconcile uh
free will
with
predetermination yeah that's interesting
conversation that's what I want to ask a
big thing for lifelong Catholics man
it's just like well
I'm responsible but I'm not there's a
grand design so if I sin that was what
God wanted right now I don't want to
alienate people who are religious I've
got all kinds of uh people who are
religious who I love and respect
with that said I think that this idea of
Heaven that we were talking about before
is so self-serving it's like I'll be
like I'll be good so that I can get into
heaven you know and like there's a
reason for your for your uh compassion
because you're like well right I get
something exactly it's very uh it's very
and it's like and then the question is
then
is that righteous well is it is it if
good things are coming from an act that
is not 100 righteous right
is it right is it good is it going to be
righteous exactly if you're like going
like well I'm doing this I'm being nice
to I'm feeding you I'm clothing you but
I'm doing it not because like yeah
because you want to go to heaven because
I want to go to heaven but it's
benefiting you you're [ __ ] getting
fed you're getting clad I think the
intention is important and like what do
they say it's like the something is its
own reward yeah yeah yeah
I think there it is you're doing it
because right it's the right thing to do
not because you're like well somebody's
gonna Pat me right back I saw a comment
on a YouTube video that I put up and it
said something about like oh you're
doing you know doing everything wrong
it's not too like like Jesus can say you
really need Jesus to save you right and
like it just kind of got under my skin a
little bit and I actually responded
which I I rarely ever do and I wrote
back I said I said you know you're right
I'm doing everything wrong but I'm just
gonna keep doing everything wrong and I
plan on letting Jesus save me later you
know like uh just the thing about Jesus
he'll come to the last minute Jesus is
cool like that on your deathbed the last
thing you think is like let me like I
accept Jesus as my savior and you're
good that washes away everything he'd I
say and I even said that like between
you know I'm gonna accept Jesus and like
so that he can wipe away all the bad
stuff I do between now and then
I mean the idea that that holds water it
just makes me so mad and that's why I
love the Life review thing because it's
not a the Life review is you're not
being punished for for the bad things
you did when you experienced the the
harm that you caused others you're not
being rewarded for the joy that you
brought people you're just experiencing
it as it was it's not a punishment it's
not a reward it is just simply the
immutable laws of of the universe the
law of cause and effect you you
experience the the you reap what you
sowed you know like it's just not good
or bad it's just that which is and
that's very very like big in the cosmos
you know like it's not we we assign good
and bad but in reality there is no good
and bad there's just simply the law of
cause and effect I am if somebody had
told me the best conversation you're
going to have about the afterlife is
going to be with Stevo one day yeah I
would have been like I'm sorry are we in
heaven when this happens
exactly I think that clip was awesome
but not as awesome as my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what I've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions which
is out September 27th and if you
pre-order it right now you can get the
autographed copy so get on it man
pre-order my book it's not going to
waste your time because I'm proven dude
New York Times bestseller my first
book's Five star rated on Amazon and I
have no doubt this one will be too so
get the autograph copy right now by
pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude